comprendre ce qu'il se passe aujourd'hui
grâce au passé et grâce aux cartes c'est
ce qu'on va essayer de faire aujourd'hui
autour du conflit israëlo palestinien et
pour ça je suis avec mayel Aldebert
bonjour mayel bonjour journaliste au
Figaro merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui euh votre article a
retrouver sur le site du Figaro du foyer
national juif aux récente guerre la
longue histoire du conflit
israélo-palestinien en carte euh on va
justement parler de cet article que vous
avez réalisé grâce aux cartes réalisé
par le service infographie euh et on va
revenir sur un peu la genèse de ce
conflit sur qu'est-ce qui l' amené euh
et déjà montré cette première carte euh
qui date de 1922 euh du mandat
britannique euh est-ce qu'on peut juste
dire rapidement ce qu'il y avait avant
cette carte oui c'est important de le
préciser euh avant cette période là
avant 1920 donc le le territoire euh de
la Palestine que qui est en fait le un
territoire qu'on appelle le territoire
de la sud-syrie la région de la
sud-syrie qui est dans l'Empire ottoman
donc est sous domination ottomane depuis
plusieurs siècles euh et c'est pendant
la Première Guerre mondiale que des
accords secrets sont passés les accords
sy Pico entre la France la grand
Bretagne et puis les puissances
victorieuses de la Première Guerre
mondiale pour le partage des décombres
de l'Empire ottomain qui qui est défait
au lendemain de la Première Guerre
mondiale donc le la Palestine et la
région qu'on voit qui est entourée en en
vert donc les deux parties vertes sont
récupéré par la la Grande-Bretagne euh
et et ces deux parties donc sont divisés
en 2 en
1922 puisque la la Grande-Bretagne cède
le la trans-jordanie euh et le la laisse
de côté du du mandat de la Palestine
effectivement vous voyez donc c'est
c'est deux endroits 1922 on imagine que
tout ne se fait pas dans
le dans le calme il y a aussi des des
des révoltes à ce moment-là là oui donc
en parallèle de ces discussions de
territoire au niveau étatique il y a
bien sûr depuis la fin du 19e une
immigration juive essentiellement au
début en provenance de Russie et
d'Europe de l'Est là où les Juifs sont
le plus victimes d'antisémitisme et
cette immigration juive donc elle
s'installe en Palestine petit à petit
elle rejoint une minorité qui qui est
toujours restée en Palestine hein depuis
le grand exode du du peuple juif à la
fin au vers 170 quand quand l'Empire
romain défait le le la grande révolte
juive de l'époque mais c'est encore une
autre histoire là là on va remonter
beaucoup trop loin voilà euh mais en
tout cas cette immigration juive qui
commence à partir de la fin du 19e
rejoint cette minorité juive dont on
estime à peu près à 3 % de la population
euh et euh et forcément euh euh est
confronté à la population euh à la
population arabe sur sur place et en
fait dans l'entre de guerre il y a
beaucoup de révoltes euh il y a
notamment la grande révolte de 1936 1939
mais on peut aussi citer une autre
révolte qui est intéressante à
mentionner en 1935 parce queelle est
menée par le Cher isaldin al-kassam euh
et et en fait ce nom-là a été repris par
les brigades du même nom les brigades
alkassam qui sont la branche militaire
du Hamas et qui considèrent ce ce cher
là ce ce chef arabe comme comme un héros
de la cause palestinienne alors ça c'est
pour la pour la première guerre mondiale
euh on arrive ensuite à la à la deuxème
guerre mondiale à la fin de de la de la
deuxème guerre mondiale on est en
1948 quand cette carte apparaît c'est
l'indépendance de l'État d'Israël voilà
c'est ça alors en fait là à ce moment-là
c'est le le partage de la Palestine en
deux états via un plan de l'ONU qui est
de la jeune organisation de des Nations
Unies oui qui vient d'être créé qui
vient d'être créé euh ce planl est voté
par le la majorité des membres de de
l'ONU et répond à une attente et un
projet qui qui a mûri les décennies
précédentes avec la déclaration Balfour
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale le
foyer national juif euh et cetera et
donc à ce moment-là le la Palestine est
divisée en deux états un État arabe et
en état et en état juif euh et et à la
suite de de de cette résolution le le
l'État d'Israël est créé à ce moment-là
le 14 mai
1948 donc après une déclaration de David
benouron qu'on qu'on nomme à juste titre
le père de l'État d'Israël alors on voit
sur cette carte que tout est estce que
c'est un territoire qui est très
morcelé c'est selon la la la qui
habitait où on
imagine à ce moment-là il y a il y a une
partie qui est
sous contrôle l'national c'est la ville
de Jérusalem oui alors il y a plein de
critères évidemment qui ont été
soigneusement étudiés pour élaborer ce
planlà dont effectivement les foyers les
foyers d'immigration juive depuis donc
depuis le la fin du 19e comme on disait
tout à l'heure et puis il y a la ville
de Jérusalem qui est prévu dans le plan
de partage pour être sous statut
international donc qui n'appartient ni à
l'un ni à l'autre euh on imagine que
tout de suite après d'ailleurs c'est les
États qui sont à côté les les les les
ces états voisins qui ne voient pas d'un
bon œil cet indépendance de d'Israël
voilà donc la majorité des des pays
arabes de la région se se ligue et
d'ailleurs ne vote pas le la la
résolution de l'ONU en 48 en 47 et se
ligue contre le le nouvel État
d'Israël et donc juste après la
déclaration de de Ben Gouron il rentre
dans les l'État d'Israël donc il y a
Cinq Armées euh il y a l'Égypte la
Jordanie la Syrie l'Irak et le Liban h
euh qui entre en guerre contre le nouvel
état donc là il y a une une première
guerre la première guerre israélo-arabe
on dit pas encore
israélo-palestinienne parce que
effectivement les pays c'est des pays
qui sont en guerre les pays arabes qui
sont en guerre contre Israël et non les
territoires palestiniens euh et donc
cette nouvelle guerre se Solle par un
une défaite cuisante des des pays arabes
euh puisque il Israël gagne
militairement et euh et oblige en fait
une grande partie de la population
palestinienne qui est euh qui est
présente sur le territoire d'Israël donc
dans les zones bleues qu'on voit euh à à
regagner le les zones les zones vertes
donc la S Jordanie puis la bande de Gaza
ce que les Arabes appellent la nagba la
la catastrophe euh c'est le ce moment-là
où 700000 700000 plus de 700000
palestiniens euh sont délogés de chez
chez eux et puis rejoignent le la bande
de Gaza puis la S Jordanie qu'on voit
dans cette autre carte voilà parce que
là nous sommes du coup en 1949 donc 2
ans après 1947 l'indépendance on voit la
différence entre ces deux cartes je vais
vous les remontrer celle-ci de 1947 où
il y avait un partage on a l'impression
à peu près 50 50 50 là c'est plutôt
Israël qui a récupéré une grande partie
du territoire voilà tout à fait et ce
qu'on voit aussi sur la carte c'est que
euh donc la Jordanie récupère la tutelle
de la de la S Jordanie et puis l'Égypte
de la de la bande de Gaza euh voilà
effectivement il y a il y a cet exode et
puis ensuite donc là nous sommes en 1947
1967 c'est une grande date forcément
puisque c'est la guerre des 6 jours oui
alors juste avant il faut aussi préciser
que donc l'immigration de juif se
poursuit h euh en 1950 c'est important
de le dire quand même le la CNÉ 7 donc
le parlement israélien vote une loi pour
favoriser le le transfert de citoyenneté
aux nouveaux arrivants juifs qui peuvent
justifier de leur de leur judaité euh et
donc ça c'est capital pour Israël
puisque euh ils ont besoin de de
personnes pour habiter exactement il y a
une bataille démographique en fait en
parallèle et et entre 1900 1900 GCH sous
les yeux entre
1949 et
1951 1948 à
1951 en 3 ans le la population d'Israël
double passe à peu près de 800000
habitants à 15 d'accord ou donc donc en
en parallèle de cette bataille
démographique évidemment il y a le désir
de de revanche des des états des États
arabes qui conduit à la guerre des 6
jours en 67 voilà la guerre des 6 jours
en 67 qui est qui est une guerre où
les à la base c'est c'est c'est une
c'est un plan d'attaque des voisins une
fois de plus contre Israël alors ce qui
se passe en fait c'est que euh
effectivement il y a il y a un projet
d'attaque et un plan d'attaque et Israël
sauf que Israël prend les devants en
fait Israël attaque le premier dans
cette stratégie le la meilleure défense
c'est c'est l'attaque euh Israël il faut
bien se rend compte que Israël c'est
vraiment un tout petit territoire euh
qui est entouré de de grands pays arabes
et on voil la Jordanie alors on voit pas
les les les les frontières adessus mais
vous imaginez le le Liban qui est
audessus la Syrie qui est assez grande
l'Égypte qui qui qui est sur la gauche
voà et il y a vraiment une crainte une
crainte existentielle he pour le pour
l'existence de enfin pour les pour la
population israélienne du coup le le
l'État d'Israël décide de de prendre les
devants euh le tsal donc attaque en
premier et en fait il gagne la guerre en
6 jours de manière vraiment complètement
sans ambiguité le premier jour il bon
bombarde toutes les bases d'aviation
etnemi donc ils détruisent en une
journée l'aviation etnemi et puis
ensuite ils déroulent et en 6 jours en 6
jours ils ont envahi le Sinaï donc on
voit toute cette c'est vrai que c'est
c'est c'est impressionnant en en 6 jours
d'arriver à récupérer autant de
territoirees la S Jordanie le Sinaï
égyptien et le plateau du Golan ouais
tout à fait donc pénètre dans le sinï
égyptien et puis dans le dans le plateau
du Golan qui est un plateau surplombant
la pleine de Damas donc stratégiquement
c'est capital pour de la voie euh et
donc le le le conflit se termine sur un
cess le feu là-dessus avec tous ces
territoires occupés par le l'armée
israélienne effectivement et vous voule
vous le voyez et puis il y a il y a il y
a une il y a une colonisation qui
commence aussi dans ces territoires qui
sont qui sont occupés par Israël voilà
donc c'est c'est effectivement le début
de la colonisation euh par exemple sur
le plateau du Galan euh ou du Golan ça
dépend com on veut le prononcer le la
colonisation commence à partir de ce
moment-là et le territoire sera
véritablement annexé en 1981 avec une
loi qui sera votée à laacnisset aussi
officiellement oui euh et ce qui n'est
pas le cas pour les deux autres
territoires donc en fait à l'issue de la
guerre des des 6 jours le l'ONU vote une
résolution
242 qui demande à Israël de de se
retirer des territoires
euh en fait Israël le fait pas euh mais
mais en fait Israël va s'en va va va
repartir euh à la prochaine guerre à la
4è guerre on pourrait dire israélo arabe
donc en en 73 à la guerre du Kipour qui
a un autre épisode effectivement parce
que c'est c'est juste 6 ans après c'est
une nouvelle attaque
euh sur son territoire exactement donc
là c'est ce qui est différent avec le la
guerre du Kipour c'est que Israël après
la victoire d' 6 jours euh penser euh à
juste titre avoir terrassé ses ennemis
et avec sa puissance militaire penser
les intimider suffisamment pour les
dissuader de toute nouvelle attaque et
en fait euh et en fait l'Égypte l'Égypte
à nouveau en chef de fil des pays arabes
avec la Syrie attaque à nouveau Israël
Israël est complètement pris par
surprise euh alors même que ils auraient
pu ils auraient pu anticiper parce que
ils avaient des informations si on
rentre dans les détails euh de de
certaines personnes qui étaient proches
de des plus hautes sphères égyptiennes
c'est pour ça qu'on a comparé la guerre
du Kipour avec ce qui s'est passé le 7
octobre dernier mais on pourrait y
revenir h donc Israël est complètement
surpris et puis finalement l'armée en 2
TR jours euh retrouve ses ses bonnes
bases et puis et puis gagne cette guerre
mais politiquement euh c'est aussi une
victoire égyptienne puisque par
l'intermédiaire des États-Unis not
notamment une une paix va être trouvée
avec l'Égypte oui effectivement donc aux
accords de cand David quelques années
plus tard oui alors c'est pour pour
voyez bien donc donc la différence entre
ces deux cartes c'est c'est le sinaai
c'est cette immense zone qui est qui est
qui au sud d'Israël qu'Israël avait
avait récupéré donc après la guerre des
6 Jours de 1967 et qui là va être
rétribué finalement par Israël à
l'Égypte voilà exactement donc ça ça
fait partie des accords ça fait partie
des des critères et des et des points
des accords de de paix de cand David
donc Israël restitue le Sinaï euh et en
échange le l'Égypte signe des accords de
paix et puis surtout reconnaît l'État
d'Israël ce qui euh ce qui entraînera
d'ailleurs le l'exclusion de l'Égypte de
de la Ligue arabe et surtout le
l'assassinat de du président égyptien
elsadat qui qui signe ses accords de
paix
euh et qui euh voilà oui parce que
jusque là là il y a il y a une
solidarité entre tous les états et là
c'est l'Égypte qui finalement fait des
euh comment dire ce ce fait fait
finalement alliance contre le retour de
de ce territoire voilà c'est ça ou ouais
tout à fait c'est c'est comme ça qu'on
pourrait
analyser la chose on va on on va
continuer pour aller un peu plus loin
pour parler un peu du du Liban c'est
cette zone au c'est la frontière nord
vous le voyez ici on va zoomer un peu
voilà le sud Liban il y a aussi des des
des invasions des invasions du du Liban
et la première a li en 1982 oui alors
donc ça c'est une autre un autre aspect
du conflit donc le après les accords de
cand David
le
l'OLP donc une faction un mouvement
palestinien de résistance palestinien se
se crée et se réfugie ils essayent de se
réfugier en Jordanie mais ça marche pas
il se réfugie ensuite au Liban pour
mener ses actions de Guera depuis depuis
le sud du Liban et c'est pour ça en fait
que Israël décide d'envahir le Liban en
1900 en
1982 euh donc ça c'est la première
invasion du Liban pour détruire le l'OLP
l'OLP de yassar Arafat effectivement euh
cette opération elle sera assez
sévèrement jugé par l'opinion
internationale parce que
euh le
les Israéliens vont décider de de rester
donc dans la partie bleue qu'on voit au
sud du Liban h
et et il y a cet épisode aussi du
massacre de chabra et de de chabra
satila par des miliciens chrétiens sous
autorité israélienne les Israéliens sont
accusés de n'avoir rien fait ce qui
entraîne d'ailleurs des grandes
manifestations à
Jérusalem de de la population
israélienne euh donc voilà tout toute
cette
opération politiquement est assez est
assez compliqué pour le pour Israël
effectivement et puis il y a C ces
accords de paix qu'on trouve au niveau
en
1993 des tentatives d'accord de paix les
les accords qu'on dit d'Oslo oui donc ça
c'est les seconds accords de paix cette
fois donc avec le l'Autorité
palestinienne de donc avec l'OLP h donc
le le l'état l'État israélien décide de
de de passer ces accords là qu'on
appelle les accords d'Oslo en 1993 euh
et les deux parties ratifient ce qu'on
ce que ce qui est appelé une déclaration
de principe sur une une autonomie
transitoire de 5 ans en réalité c'est ce
qui avait déjà été fait lors des Accords
de de cand David donc en fait c'est une
deuxième tentative euh et et cette
autonomie transitoire elle va aussi euh
elle va aussi être très compliquée être
mise en place pour dans le contexte
qu'on va voir ensuite euh parce que en
parallèle vont être déclencher les Inada
donc les révoltes populaires on pourrait
dire
palestiniennes qui vont mettre à mal
cette cette autonomie politique puisque
israël va vouloir constamment contrôler
militairement euh pour justifiant de sa
propre
sécurité C
il y avait deux hommes qui ont qui ont
fait ces ces accords de solo il y a une
poignée de main historique c'est une
image qu'on connaitt tous entre y arfat
et
itsakraabin d'ailleurs itacraabin sera
assassiné 2 ans 2 ans plus tard oui par
un extrémiste juif opposé au processus
de paix h donc voilà il y a plein de
manœuvres assez
complexes et ça effectivement c'est
aussi des éléments à prendre en
compte mais mais en réalité cette ces
accords de paix vont être vraiment mis à
mal mal par les par les Intifada même si
c'est vraiment plusieurs mouvements en
parallèle la deuxème Intifada commence
en 2000 euh et elle est elle commence en
fait après la visite à Jérusalem Dariel
chararon euh qui est à l'époque le chef
de l'opposition de droite israélienne
après la visite derrière Sharon sur
l'planè des mosquées donc l' planè des
mosquées c'est euh qui se tient sur le
la colline du monond du temple c'est là
où se tenait Temple de Jérusalem qui
étaé détruit en 70 par le par l'empereur
par l'empereur romain qui est considérit
donc comme un lieu sacré par par le
peuple hébreu et qui est aussi un lieu
un lieu sain pour l'Islam euh donc après
cette visite là après cette visite
euh que certains ont qualifié de
provocation le il y a une deuxème tifada
euh donc une révolte assez violente qui
va cette fois entraîner le retrait donc
de l'armée israélienne de la bande de
Gaza oui c'est ils vont partir de de la
bande de
Gaza ils vont réoccuper des des villes
en en
sjordanie par justement de de ce retrait
il y a il y a cette histoire aussi à ce
moment-là d'un d'un soldat israélien qui
s'appelle Gilat Chalit oui qui c'est qui
qui est par qui qui qui est enlevé qui
sera libéré en en 200 contre plus de
plus de 1000 prisonniers palestiniens et
ça on en parle aujourd'hui avec
forcément ce contexte d'otage exactement
euh donc ça c'est aussi un épisode qui
qui va marquer le l'histoire entre
Israël et la bande de
Gaza l'armée israélienne se retire en
2005 de la bande de Gaza et en fait va
instaurer suite notamment à cet
enlèvement va instaurer tout un blocus
autour de la mande de Gaza et et en plus
en parallèle le Hamas prend le la
possession du territoire
électoralement donc israël va imposer un
blocus autour de la bande de Gaza qui va
qui va jamais cesser de se
renforcer et qui se renforce ces
dernières années par un mur un mur ultra
sophistiqué qui est construit qui été
construit pour un milliard de de dollars
qui devait être impénétrable qui devait
être impénétrable mais qui l'a
visiblement pas été un mur antiunnel
donc quelque chose de très ce qui avec
des capteurs des voilà que les
terroristes du Hamas ont ont franchi par
les air on franchit avec un bulldozer on
contourné par la mer le 7 octobre
dernier effectivement on peut parler de
la de la on a parlé d'une première
invasion aussi au au au Liban il il y en
a une deuxième à partir de 2006 du coup
dans le dans le dans le nord du pays
donc au sud du Liban voilà il y en a une
deuxème à partir de 2006 alors cette
fois-ci c'est plus contre l'OLP euh mais
c'est contre le le mouvement du esbola
euh mouvement chit du esbola qui est
soutenu par l'Iran et qui s'est réfugié
comme l'OLP en son temps dans le sud du
Liban et qui et qui mène des attaques
depuis là et donc et donc Israël décide
décide de réitérer l'opération donc
envahir le Liban jusqu'à beyouth si même
jusqu'à bombarder Beyrouth
euh et donc et donc ça c'est aussi un un
fait marquant qui qui d'ailleurs va
beaucoup marqué la conscience
libanaise et et aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui le le hbola a vraiment est
vraiment une des menaces
principales dans cette à cette frontière
n là puis vraiment avec des équipements
militaires une organisation qui bien
supériur au Hamas exactement et avec un
financement donc avec un financement
directement en provinance d'Iran
effectivement je voulais montrer cette
cette derni dernière carte c'est la
carte que nous avons aujourd'hui de la
de la situation en en 2023 on peut
revenir sur une chose d'abord aussi
c'est mars 2018 c'est des moments où il
y a des
rassemblements on parlait de de ce mur
cette barrière re de Gaza il y a des
manifestations qui ont lieu souvent le
long de ce de cette barrière oui donc ça
c'est très régulier depuis depuis
quelques années en parallèle il y a
beaucoup d'événements qui vont qui vont
ponctuer manifestation comme euh par
exemple en en 2018 le la reconnaissance
de Jérusalem euh comme capitale de
l'État d'Israël par les États-Unis donc
les les États-Unis transfèrent leur
ambassade de TelAviv à Jérusalem ce qui
symboliquement est très fort donc ça
c'était une décision qui était prise par
Donald Trump qui n'a pas été suivie par
les autres les autres puissances
occidentales est-ce qu'on peut voir
aussi sur sur la carte et ce dont on a
pas parlé c'est la division après les
accords de d'Oslo du territoire
palestinien en plusieurs
zones une zone directement en orange
administré par le l'Autorité
palestinienne et puis ensuite on peut
voir en bleu le toutes ces ces colonies
ces implantations juives euh israélienne
que le que l'État d'Israël d'ailleurs ne
reconnaît pas en tant que colonie
euh et et qui sont aussi du point de vue
des palestinens une source de tension
évidemment euh on estime donc ce cette
ces colonies à plus de de
750000 700 710000 en 2021 donc on doit
être autour de de
750000 donc autant dans le en sjordanie
que à Jérusalem Est et puis là on le
voit pas mais un peu au-dessus dans le
plateau du du Golan il y a on estime
qu'il y a environ 20000 20000 colons oui
on rappelle le plateau du Golan qui
appartient officiellement à la Syrie
mais qu'Israël revendique vien en 1980
exactement donc le le plateau du GAN il
a vraiment été annexé he par le par
Israël en en
1981 mais mais ce cette annextion est
pas reconnue par la par la communauté
internationale à part par les
États-Unis depuis depuis très peu donc
depuis quelques années pareil sur
décision du du président Donald Trump
euh on peut avant d'arriver sur 2023 il
y a en 2021 il y a il y a il y a des
heurs qui éclatent aussi sur les
planètes des mosquées justement oui euh
donc en 2021 il y a il y a effectivement
ces heurtes là euh le Hamas depuis euh
depuis continuer à lancer des des
milliers de roquettes vers Israël
euh et avec ce ce ce début de révolte
sur les sur les spat des des mosquées
euh c'est aussi le début d'une nouvelle
guerre de 11 jours euh qui va être qui
va durer 11 jours entre le Hamas et
l'État hébreux donc c'était il y a 2 ans
à peine et et cette guerre là elle a
débouché sur un cesser le feu assez
fragile évidemment on le voit depuis le
depuis le 7 octobre et en parallèle donc
ça c'est ça concerne Gaza et puis ça ça
concerne aussi la S Jordanie puisque en
parallèle l'armée israélienne en en août
2022 donc il y a un peu plus d'un an va
lancer des hostilités contre le le
Djihad islamique donc qui une autre
fation palestinienne
euh une autre faction palestinienne donc
voilà et en fait depuis cette époque là
il y a il y a vraiment régulièrement des
heurs au début de l'année 2023 en
janvier ça elle a mené un raid sur
génine en en S Jordanie euh donc il y a
eu pareil y a eu des affrontements à ce
moment-là h euh donc donc voilà nous
c'est pour ça qu'on a j'ai noté dans mon
article nouveaux embrasements oui c'est
nouveaux embrasements parce que vous
comprenez bien maintenant effectivement
tout tout toute l'histoire qu'on vous a
qu'on vous a remis en contexte je vous
rappelle toutes ces cartes qu'on vous a
montré que vous pouvez d' d'ailleurs
retrouver mais je vais mettre votre
article qui est ici du foyer national
juif aux récentes guerre la longue
histoire du conflit seropestinien en
carte que vous pouvez trouver sur le
site du Figaro merci beaucoup Mael de
vert d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui
Merci à VOUS du Figaro d'avoir été
nombreux à nous suivre et moi je vous
dis à bientôt pour de live sur Figaro
live à 16h c'est votre prochain
rendez-vous vous aurez la question du
jour à tout de suite sur Figaro
live